hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to in Lucy's eyes I
actually had to step away for the
commuter for a little bit to give myself
a breather because I was about to have a
heart attack from the last moment but
I'm back in the water now and I'm pretty
sure they're not gonna throw a water
monster at me whoa hey whoa okay all
right that was me freaking myself out by
the water pouring over there I thought I
thought I thought like right in that
moment they were gonna throw a water
else at me never mind okay I'm good
all right so I think that's his door out
of his own correct
oh yes okay so how's about free forget
about him it's a teddy bear
that's the teddy bear for the first part
of the game the chandelier head oh there
was the lady sitting in the far corner
that was the first drawing from what I'm
assuming Lucy that had the eyes from my
lovely wife looking at me at least I'm
assuming it's my lovely wife this may
all be the cruel ploy of Lucy herself
now I need to oh there's a little bit of
lag going down here Oh what was that
what is that what is that over there
what is that okay all right some weird
reflection but okay so I just need to be
very mindful of what I'm doing and why
is the framerate dropping very hard
sometimes these custom stories they get
a little ambitious and they load up too
many items in one area she's got to be
mindful about everything looks like I'm
probably gonna be either picking up some
acid my pees popping a little too much
sorry it's trying to keep my mind
focused on what's going on and make sure
that everything's recording properly
because I would hate for something to go
terribly terribly wrong
I don't know why but I was trying to I
was trying to form cohesive thoughts in
the last part but it wasn't it wasn't it
just wasn't happening and what I was
trying to say is that I haven't had the
heebie-jeebies while playing a game in a
long long time and this game like
delivers in droves I'm not even like
spouting record rattled oh god I cannot
talk I'm not trying to spout rhetoric or
anything here rhetoric rhetoric rhetoric
can I not say words right now I'm not
trying to spout rhetoric in saying that
this game is extremely scary
oh come on I mean there's a thing
what does that mean why okay then I'm
fine all right
okay that's usually the music that picks
up when something bad is about to happen
but combined with all the new music I
don't know if that's acknowledging that
something is gonna happen or if
something is already happening
nevermind so now I need to stop that
water wheels spinning too fast to pass
it can I find a way to slow it down
probably by throwing something into it I
mean that works before this seems good
enough how about a little bit of
I probably needed that for something
else but a little bit
so there's got to be a mechanical
solution to this problem all right I
just got a bad feeling about everything
because Y is the thumpy thump pumping
away there's no real reason for that oh
here we go I'll miss that okay so that
can go to the engine room wherever how
that is oh oh oh there oh he's trying to
communicate my name is markiplier have
you seen a tiny box he's so tiny this
isn't him this is not him
okay what am I gonna do to get away from
this guy cuz there's only one way back
now he's blind so I'm wondering if he
might just go away oh he's not gonna go
ahead okay so I think I what I'm gonna
do there we go
I don't know how they scripted him to be
down
Oh
what a minute hee-hee-hee-hee-hee
okay okay come on
can't see anything
okay okay okay okay okay
okay that guy is not fun times that
guy's not happy fun laughing so we have
a puzzle here rusty and stuck oh no do I
have to go find some oil oh no where am
I gonna find some oil I don't know
can I find some oil from one of these
conveniently closed pipes crap I'm gonna
have to go back out and try to find some
booby booby booby why does it have to be
so damn dark
okay we're okay
Roque everything is just fine everything
is hunky-dory I'm sorry if my commentary
is not exactly up to par right now huh
I'm not exactly in the mood to be saying
a whole lot I'm in the mood to be
surviving a whole lot damn it I don't
know where I'm gonna get oil there
probably was some place to get oil back
were them rotating back where the
rotating machine was but I have no idea
if I want to go back there just yet
kind of want to make sure that I'm
a-okay over here am i doing bad because
I'm sarin atom or am i doing bad just
because I've been standing in the dark
for quite a while
Clawd I heard him oh oh I thought I'd
oh okay I need to stop being such a big
baby about things I need to be a big
baby laughing right now okay okay okay
we're fine where do I go what do I do
the way to put it up oh nothing nothing
here I'm not here what are you deaf what
are you blind
you're crazy happy nose ah I'm still
alive okay okay my still alive you punch
like a girl and by that I mean you put
really hard ow
be careful no oh here I thought I was
supposed to thump around like a great
rampaging monster
where's no oil where do I use oil okay
what that's not fair
where is he now where am i now I don't
know where I is where did I spawn where
is where is am i where am is I
does this lead to the this is the
machine room thing I can't see a damn
thing
okay no it's not okay so where is this I
already been in here
I found the glass jar in here okay so
there's got to be a place nearby where
there's oil or else I'm just an idiot do
I need to go back no I wouldn't need to
go back it had to be in that room that I
was in
or I just got murdered I mean I was
really careful I was like really careful
actually maybe not in here
that oil little wheel there anybody want
a jar the jar anybody got some oil that
we want to give over to me anything up
there that I need no all right so oh oh
oh I was almost right
I was almost right it was right in here
I just didn't see this Luke did I get it
yes okay I got it I got it and I think
the big guy is gone actually he did not
respawn which is kind of a bug of the
original amnesia game if you got killed
by a monster he kind of just disappeared
which I think there definitely got a fix
when they do soma which apparently is
supposed to be releasing sometime this
year
oh god is so dark why's it gotta be so I
can't see anything either guys I see
nothing I see nothing at all okay so if
I do this and there's gonna do that I'm
gonna be able to
come on come on what there we go come on
all the way all the way okay so now it
should be slow enough for me to go
through and then I should be able to
move forward can't see can't see you
can't see totally blind
alrighty going I think where I need to
go ah it's dark ok there we go
alrighty then and everything is good and
we're making progress ok so now I should
be able to pass with relative ease yeah
I guess a capacitor that's gonna kill me
don't kill me okay we're fine we're fine
we're fine got it got it got it ok
forget someone didn't like that sorry
gonna jump please thank you okay I'm
okay why is there so much water why is
it always ankle level it's by who
oh well suddenly there's no water for
some reason okay I need to be
conservative with my he just wanted to
go for a swim apparently that's a rather
deep pool ain't gonna be caught dead in
that I might be caught dead in that but
that's a whole nother story okay what am
I looking at okay
the water level is too high to get past
the iron gate I mean I could swim but
whatever who would do that
not me I'm scared down just say oh it
says nothing there's no point doing that
I just wasted another damn match you
need to stop wasting my matches I don't
need to cross I need to use the bridge
like a smarty move I need to go over
here what I can't see anything I really
don't want to miss anything that's why
I'm trying to use up these when I can
stop getting stuck on [ __ ] oh okay
all right I got it whoa wait what that's
new okay did not notice this before how
did I miss this I'm an idiot
what does this do come on now show me
what you got
blank ok did that bring the water
finally am i gonna finally be on dry
land thank you very much ok so now
should be able to get through this iron
gay glam oh I'm still in water great and
it's still dark I love life I love to
love life life is lovely no not that
that's not what I wanted why did you
think I wanted that Pam okay fine fine
fine fine fine fine where are we going
okay I'm going to the door got you guys
got okay good good good good good making
progress bacon bacon it make it make me
okay
alright any nightmares in there any bad
things that I need to know about that
sounds fun Dom just tearing through my
matches I really didn't think I was
actually gonna run oh don't do that to
me jeez don't randomly jerk around my
camera I don't even know if that was me
or you but jeez don't do that okay I
think I'm actually gonna take a little
moment to stop here because I think I'm
out of time so thank you everybody so
much for watching get ready for the next
part real soon
cuz I'm gonna keep playing I'm brave or
whatever so thanks again everybody and
as always I will see you in the next one
bye bye
did you ever see pageant troopers these
returnees right into his mouth
believe it